hello and welcome to the new world
review where today kilwa has a sixth or
seventh sense a wolfy boy starts off
fully understanding what's happening
then confusing himself so much that it
just makes more of a mess of the
situation we're already in and a tarot
makes a
timely return okay good let's get into
it episode 110
and we have to ask the question now
where is palm
where is she because everyone seems to
be wondering that same thing and not
actually having that information cleared
up
is becoming suspicious now if she's not
there where could she have gone
none of the royal guards seemed to care
or have mentioned it so we can only
assume she actually survived in some way
right meanwhile we have kamugi sad
because she thinks the king didn't tell
her his name because he's not or doesn't
want to be her friend rather than not
telling her because he
actually doesn't know himself the point
made by the others is a very solid one
a good reason why there would be a
switch in n and a very good reason for
guard changes or why the guard wouldn't
be around is because the king
is reproducing what we don't actually
know or at least that i
i don't know is how an ant with ken
dole-like smoothness reproduces
especially with
a human and i know that i could easily
spend a lot of time philosophizing on
this concept but i
really also am very aware that i
shouldn't so it's very likely that
they're going to storm the palace get
all the way to the throne room and
see the most sensual strategic game ever
being played right
wow betide them if they accidentally
kill komugi
thinking she's an ant oh also we had
another amp turn up that we haven't seen
in a while
the one who seems to eat nen she was
gone but now she's back and i'm not sure
why
i really do hope she eats nen forget
about her though the mvp of that scene
was the ant with her who had some really
intense facial emotions
honestly i feel like this arc would not
be what it is without that specific
little ant she mocks and who's like
i understand you but i just don't have
anything to say to you not because i
can't talk but like you're an awful
person and i'm a butler ant the thing is
though if we're seeing her again it
means that she's about to become
relevant in some way so i guess
i wonder if she can give and take nen
powers the same way leo could but by
eating them i really hope it's by eating
them there are a lot of ants who can
manipulate other
nen powers at will and that's such an
interesting thing to be a regular
behavior because it seems opie
like the queen must have eaten a lot of
manipulators or the kind of
men that does that i don't know it seems
like manipulation but i don't know if
it's i don't know how
i've forgotten jumping around a little
something i'm loving about the way these
last few episodes have been balanced is
that we're getting closer and closer to
the point at which the groups are going
to meet and part of that is knowing
information they don't and questioning
what information and what assumptions
they would have come to
in storyboarding this i do wonder
whether tagashi did them separately and
interspersed them or wrote the scenes
back to back to keep track of them
that kind of thing is fascinating to me
because all these characters are so
individually developed and clear and
that's something i love about the series
that each of the characters of interest
become fully fleshed out the
disagreements they have when they do get
into them deeply
come from such an informed place that we
know exactly why that character made
that decision keela our constant
suspicious companion lives in a world
where there is always something missing
from an equation but what we also know
is that in this case kilwa is right and
if the others don't take his concerns
seriously the ants are going to
immediately win
probably the tension i felt when wolfy
boy decided to go stand where nob left
his portal was fairly pronounced and i
love hearing these miscommunications and
potential moments of disconnect
can we spend a moment looking at how
much of a butch australian
surfy boy wolf boy is and and
how desperate he is to be the king
behind the scenes like he has that's his
phrase i'mma be the king behind the
scenes
yeah all these characters have spent so
much time trying to take over each
other's positions and the constant
hiding of information is going to result
in some hilarious miscommunication down
the line
especially since we now have bizarre
confused and hunting palm but also
trying to manipulate the situation what
tagashi seems to be doing
is trying to introduce so much confusion
that no matter what happens we accept it
was possible or at least that's what it
feels like is happening
either way i'm expecting some seriously
intense confusion on the ground level of
this palace and now that pito can't do
anything about
komugi and must stay away from the king
there are vulnerabilities in their
defenses that very specifically confuse
things even more
not to mention shayla perth struggling
to understand that maybe the king has
found a partner in life and i think he's
right actually
of everyone in this situation shia and
kilauea probably have the most insight
into what's actually happening i feel as
though they would get on quite well if
this were any other circumstance
something that i'm noticing
is that mary's personality seems to be
fraying he keeps switching between the
desire and acknowledgement of his power
and the softness he wants to show komugi
and i'm not sure which he wants to do
i'm not sure he knows which he wants to
do because he's clearly in love right
the reality of this is that he's
softening but unsure how to incorporate
it into who he was and
i think there's going to be a lot of
confusion between the various combatants
in this because as bad as mary appears
to be
and as bad as we were led to believe he
was at the beginning those aspects of
him are cracking
he's still remarkably powerful and he's
still a callous creature toward everyone
else but the change in his behavior that
revolves around his need to be an
independent figure and to learn who he
is out of sight of the guards shouldn't
be understated it's why teenagers the
world over
reach an age where they want their
bedroom door closed you want to be free
to engage in all those behaviors that
help you to navigate who you are
and how you want to live in the world as
well as
you know to let off some steam besides
if mary is still
trying to decide what he wants to do
with komugi and he realizes that what he
wants to do
actually is breed with her he probably
wants to keep that process to himself
honestly with octobuddy becoming a spy
network and mary getting some genuine
time entirely alone with komugi
potentially to figure out what his name
is
let's take a look at episode 111 and see
what actually happens
111 and it's time to go through speaking
of time this episode felt longer than
other episodes there is something
marvelous about the use of time in shows
and in combat and i am a huge
huge proponent of the stretching and
dilation of time to engage
story this entire episode felt almost
twice the length of the previous
episodes but didn't drag
for a moment as far as reviewing goes i
feel like i'm going to need to talk
a little bit faster because i have so
many thoughts about this that i
almost can't keep up with my brain on it
the tarot being so calm and so chilled
and aware that he could die this whole
time has been quite the blessing
and the knowledge that he can manipulate
time or maybe that he can engage the use
of it through gratitude is the most
pure thing i've ever heard there's also
a really enjoyable aspect to all of this
which is the engagement of the narrator
up to now i felt that the narrator was
narrating just for the sake of it while
they added to the story mechanically the
narration didn't alter my perception of
the story it didn't
halt or extend emotion or change my
feelings in any way that was meaningful
a fun thing for me is that i experience
something we call for a lack of a better
way of describing it time blindness
i can look at my watch once and five
minutes have passed then look at it
again what feels like you know a moment
later and three hours have and i don't
really have any meaningful understanding
of how that happened
what it does mean though is that any
manipulation of time and shows gives me
probably a more powerful reaction than
others who are aware of the
consistent passage of time because
frankly speaking i felt like that
episode lasted an hour
an enjoyable hour but an hour and i can
feel in myself that now i am
actually funnily enough hyper focused
because that's the effect when you mess
with
time when you slow it everything that
happens becomes
individually important by describing
every second in those two minutes down
to milliseconds
we sat in the minds of pito and atera as
they learned
what they learned we sat in the mind of
the old zoldic
dude old dude zoldick papa zoldick we
traveled with natero through his entire
past and arrived with him
at the point where he could competently
use that skill and i
loved every minute of it i'm not sure if
this is the case but the art of this
episode was some of the most detailed
and beautiful art i've seen of this arc
so far the shift in pito's eyes was
phenomenal
the use of light and shade with natero
and the depth of color in the
environments was unlike anything i've
seen since
possibly the first dark when they
emerged from the run at the beginning of
the hunter exam
it's like we've been in the dark for so
long that seeing the beauty of mountains
and waterfalls was a reminder that there
are things outside the conflict we've
been focused on and it pulled me away
from that brilliantly
and yet despite not focusing on the
psychological responses deeply we still
focused on those psychological responses
deeply
pito's entire reaction pito's entire
response and their one-track
actions as a result of that came as a
beautiful counterpoint to natero's
stillness
because in that moment it almost seemed
as though the focus pito had couldn't
even begin to compare to the stillness
and clarity natero gave us
and that was communicated through the
stillness of the art the fracturing of
lines and the shifting of eye colour
that showed
just how competent these characters both
are despite the situation at play
pito's decisions and behaviors were so
obvious and clear and shia laperfe's
single-mindedness to the exclusion of
all
else suddenly and immediately showed all
their flaws in one moment
the plan as it's being executed is
currently on point and unexpectedly so
is notero 110 years old is that a
deliberate combination with the episode
number i know it's episode 111 but if
we're gonna spend the whole episode on
one character i'll take that unexpected
time as i've said before
the moment you decide to involve time in
a situation where looking at the passing
of it and every second becomes important
here we didn't even look at seconds we
looked at something deeper and smaller
but in those two minutes we also had
gone dropping into the monster he is his
eye is going from the green we assume
his eyes are in order to keep his color
palette in check to the flat black of
someone with a task to do
someone looking for revenge and knowing
it will take work to achieve
of course kilwa our resident emotional
teen kid is the one who notices it but
now is the time for it to arrive
right this episode was set up by having
a ticking clock over them speaking and
it did not at all disappoint
the art was beautiful the sound design
understated and
all in all it was an episode that is
hard for me to say anything bad about or
even
particularly joking about because it
drew me in just that deeply
the only moment that i found funny
within my intense focus was the fact
that atero was an old man when he was a
baby he's the sort of character that's
hard to place age-wise because he has
that goku thing of
old as time itself and newborn behavior
outside of combat i'm not sure what the
reference to lady garanin guanine
gyanian
but maybe we'll find out and i'm not
sure why a monster was born in his
punches because they're punches of
gratitude not knowing now doesn't mean i
won't understand later though and with
fists faster than sound i imagine
there's going to be some pretty intense
combat coming up
since i don't know exactly what that
combat's going to be and i want to know
that's it from me
if you enjoyed this neurodivergent deep
dive into time and focus click here here
and here
hit like share subscribe and i'll see
you next time